justin trudeau wanted to meet face to
face today with as many commonwealth
leaders as he could and he literally
went from a to z starting with the prime
minister of antigua and barbuda and
finishing with the president of zambia
my dear brother justin certainly a
pleasure the top priority for the 30 or
so island states here getting big
countries like canada to help with
climate change it is the most
significant threat facing the caribbean
region trudeau is sympathetic always a
pleasure to sit down with a friend from
the caribbean but trudeau's bigger
mission here is to convince leaders of
the 10 commonwealth states that
abstained when the u.n voted to condemn
russia's invasion of ukraine to change
their minds canada believes that adding
the censure of the commonwealth
representing 54 countries and more than
2 billion people will help ukraine one
argument canada is making connect the
dots between russia's illegal invasion
and food shortages many african and
caribbean nations are facing as a result
indeed all leaders here spent about half
the day discussing food security and
food price inflation but it will be
difficult for trudeau to find a
commonwealth consensus on russia and
ukraine because so many key leaders
skipped this summit india and south
africa for example abstained at the u.n
on the russia vote and neither country's
leader is at this summit but officials
tell us they're worried that the word
ukraine may not even be in the final
statement or communique that will be
issued tomorrow when the summit wraps up
farah
david aiken and rwanda thank you david